your 401k maybe taking a hit this week
after another sell-off the Dow the
Nasdaq and the S&P each lost more than
one-and-a-half percent of their value
yesterday the second straight day of
losses
president Trump placed the blame on his
political foes and quote impeachment
nonsense CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here to explain what's
really behind the drop Jill good morning
so what's behind the job well you know
we've been talking about this
generalized slowdown in the global
economy it's been going on for about a
year now and I think that there was new
evidence specifically here in the US of
a further slowdown we had a
manufacturing index fall to a ten-year
low this is pretty stunning now I know
manufacturing is not the whole economy
it's probably about 11 percent of the
economy eight percent of jobs but it
does tell you that there is a slowdown
in place some disappointing numbers on
jobs and also of course trade tensions
just yesterday the World Trade
Organization has basically said the US
can go and impose new tariffs on
European goods so trade tangents all
over the world
put a pail on everything and put it all
together and you have a nasty sell-off
giulia markets hate uncertainty and an
impeachment inquiry creates uncertainty
for impeachment nonsense as a president
yes I think there is what do you think
the factor is with that I think that
that is true it is uncertainty but I
think these other issues are probably
much more important I do think that
market jitters get escalated when there
is a feeling of a cloud of uncertainty
as you say now when you go back and look
at the other impeachments I'm not going
back to Johnson I don't remember that
one too well but I will say that usually
what has happened in these cases where
there is some problem in DC that the
underlying trend gets amplified so if
the underlying trend is that we're
worried about a slowdown we're worried
about a recession and this uncertainty
could lead us to then say oh my gosh I
don't want to do anything and that's the
concern so let's get down to practical
advice people have money in the markets
what do they do I think that if you are
a long-term investor that means you
don't need the money for five or ten
years you really want us to stick to
your game plan I get it it's
nerve-racking but you got a plan stick
to it if you need your money within the
next 12 months a home
payment I gotta buy a car I got to write
a tuition trick that money never should
have been at risk so you're gonna have
to go bite the bullet take the money out
and move on now if you're just nervous
you're just sort of a worried investor
in general maybe you've got too much
risk in general in that portfolio maybe
it's time to do something different but
if you're gonna move your allocation
around if you're gonna move your pieces
around don't then second-guess yourself
as soon as the market goes up again that
is not a good thing that's called trying
to time the market all right Jill /
thank you very much